welcome back i don't know what's worse
the stupidity and authoritarianism of
the lockdowns or the sickening
hypocrisy of the democrat lockdown
leaders who break their own rules
pelosi in the hair salon feinstein in
the
private airport without a mask lightfoot
in the crowd
and the hair salon and then the big one
gavin newsom
no large gathering stay outdoors social
distancing wear a mask between
bites unless of course you make those
rules in which case you can break every
single one of them
as he did in that notorious french
laundry
dinner lisa i think there's a really
good reason why this has really
um just got everyone enraged
not just here in california where i live
but across the country is such a symbol
of
the fact that if they really believed
that that all the things they're saying
were important to public health
they wouldn't break their own rules but
they do break their own rules
which undermines everything they're
saying
exactly so why should californians
follow the rules if their governor
does not and why should they believe the
rules are for a science-based reason
if the governor does not but i think
what it really does is it epitomizes
what the ruling class actually thinks of
their citizens
they think nothing of them because gavin
newsom thinks it's fine for his kids to
previously for them to go to
a private school well public schools are
shut down and those kids are falling
further
behind but his kids are entitled to
getting a better education and not
falling behind or you look at lori
lightfoot
going getting her hair cut while barber
shops and salons were
closed while people couldn't feed their
kids they couldn't open up they couldn't
cut hair they couldn't make
a living it's the same thing to be said
for the philadelphia
mayor going out eating indoors in
maryland
while indoor restaurants were closed at
the time in philadelphia
i mean it's really just despicable and
it's a reflection of how they actually
view their citizens yeah which is very
little because while they are struggling
or why families can't go and see
or you can't say goodbye to loved ones
or can't honor an individual's life at a
funeral family member's life at a
funeral they're going and breaking the
rules it's disgusting to be honest it
really it's outrageous
i totally feel you lisa um they're just
words aren't enough to express
how angry we all feel charlie it seems
to me watching their response
the politician's response look at the
way police say you need to get my hair
done and whatever
um to be fair at least gavin newsom at
least apologize but the way he did it
seems to me they consider this to be
some kind of
minor gaffe yeah we make mistakes it's
like screw up there's a little political
cost and we move on i think it's much
deeper than that
i think they just have no idea how this
totally destroys people's faith not just
in them
personally but in government in this
whole mantra of listen to the experts in
science
this is a really deep thing that's being
exposed here
well that's exactly right and i'm
waiting for them to really care i mean
it's kind of half apologies or blaming
restaurants blaming gatherings blaming
hair salons if i couldn't have picked a
more stereotypical place for gavin
newsom to break these
codes that he issued then french laundry
in napa valley anyone who's been in napa
valley knows exactly what i'm talking
about
it is one of the most expensive ruling
class waiting for a month to get a
reservation
restaurants in the country but it also
reveals a deeper point about the left
every position that they publicly
advance
they contradict whether it be in
firearms they say they want to
compensate guns they walk around with
armed guards
borders they say they don't want a wall
yet they live in gated communities
police they don't like the police except
having the police come to their
communities when they need them or in
schools and education
they say they don't like private schools
or charter schools but they send their
kids to those schools the same with
these virus lockdowns they say that you
must stay at home shelter in place in
curfews
unless you're a the divine right of king
of gavin newsom who runs california then
you can go to french
laundry and not live under the rules
that you give others
where's this going matt is there any way
that people can fight back
i mean i just you know i hear people
talk about civil disobedience what do
you think
it moved to florida we actually believe
in freedom there and the fact that
charlie clerk kirk knows so much about
french laundry shows how much more
cultured he is than i am
i thought gavin newsom was actually
going to do the laundry
when i first saw this news report but i
have a confession to make to you steve
i too have violated the washington dc
lockdowns when i got a haircut and it
you know so i've got no blame for
speaker pelosi or anyone else that feels
the need to do their hair
but it sort of felt like a drug deal we
had to meet in an undisclosed location
operate only in cash and you know like
not look at each other in the eyes too
much during this haircut
transaction i'm sure the fact that i've
admitted this now means that
a special counsel will likely be
appointed there'll be a series of ethics
investigations
but the difference between me and pelosi
and newsom is that i'm not sorry
i think that the danger isn't in a
maskless governor of california the
danger
comes with these lockdowns that punish
blue-collar people
they punish folks who don't have the
ability to just work from home
and they're deeply unfair to our fellow
americans and we should stand against
them
exactly because you you are pro haircut
you are pro
business pro haircut
i'm for it
he thought that gavin newsom was doing
the french's laundry that's why
[Laughter]
i think we're gonna have to leave it
there especially if we start getting
into gavin newsom's haircut which you
really don't want to know about